Hey, Doug Walker here.
No Rob this time, so sorry.
He didn't make it to the screening.
But yeah, I am just going to talk about Deadpool.
Uh, before I talk about the movie I should
talk about, uh, what I know about Deadpool, which actually isn't much.
Uhh, everytime I go to a con, there's like a million Deadpools.
So I know he's a really popular character.
I know he's aware he's a fictional character,
so there's a lot of fourth wall jokes.
I know he's like,
an action hero who can't like.. or kind of an anti-hero,
and he does a lot of comedy because he knows he's a character.
And he, like, can get shot and either doesn't feel the pain or heals up or something like that.
Even then I'm still not entirely sure- And he has a thing for Chimichangas.
That's about all I know.
So in terms of like "Does this represent the source material?", whatever, I'm only guessing.
Uuuh, but I'm gonna come out just as a movie critic here and uh,
As a movie like this goes...
It's fine. (Laughs)
It's got some laughs, its got some good action. Uh...
And that's about it.
um.. I think there's a lotta hype around this movie, and...
It, in no way disappoints.
Uh, I think it gives you exactly what you think you're going to get,
and that's it.
Umm, and the audience I saw it with was very very excited,
and very happy to see it,
and laughing at every single joke,
and getting invested when it got dramatic. And...
Yeah, I sure saw it as that was fun that was enjoyable, and...
I never need to see it again.
It's one of those movies where I kind of thought, maybe
the humor was gonna be even a little bit more, if that makes sense, like... kinda like "Hot Fuzz",
Uh, you know, or "World's End" where there's just so many jokes being thrown at you,
but it's... And they're good jokes!
Uh, and they're good "in the moment" jokes,
and there are good fourth wall breaking jokes...
Umm...
But... yeah, I think the one weakness it has I said in my Bum Review too is that
when it needs to be a regular movie, like when it needs to do the dramatic stuff,
Uh...it's not bad by any means,
but it's very standard.
This is very much the kind of movie you see, where...
Those movies you see advertised,
where they always take place at night, and it's lit by street lights,
and someone's wearing a hat like this,
and is really musclebound and gets revenge, because somebody
did him wrong or kidnapped his girl or something like that,
or killed his dog. Some weird crap like that...
And I'm just going around with guns shooting guys except there's a few super heroes in it,
and fourth wall jokes, not even that many superheroes...
Weird ones that they picked too and I don't know if this ties into
the comic, because we have Colossus from X-Men and some other one I don't recognize.
She has some sort of long elaborate name, but
they were both really cool. Honestly this is...
I feel like this is...
Kinda the best X-Men movie we've gotten yet because,
when Colossus comes out, he's Russian, he looks like Colossus,
He's the size, he has the personality, he's kinda, you know,
(Russian accent) he's kinda nice, almost gentlemanly,
almost very simple, and that kinda felt like what Colossus was.
He's not just a big muscle guy who's like "I can help you" and that's it, you know?
He's Russian, he's all these things, and...
There's a scene where he's just watching T.V.
and the teen girl that can blow up, I forget her name, uh, not Jubilee,
A different one, much cooler one.
Ya know, they're just watching T.V. and he goes:
"Oh, we should go help" and they just go get the Blackbird and fly out.
I sort of felt like yeah, that's X-Men, that's comic books.
And this is very much a comic book movie.
Like I said, with a lot of these, breaking the fourth-wall jokes
And... So I like that,
and I like a lot of the, like I said, a lot of the humor.
There's a romance between Ryan Reynolds and the other lead, I don't know her name, sorry.
But they have legitimately good chemistry,
they're both kind of nutty and make these one-liners.
But she's not just a carbon-copy of him either.
Ya know, which is nice, she's her own unique character.
The villain's pretty standard, the side characters that help is pretty standard.
It's funny 'cause this movie actually opens up as the funniest opening credits.
Where the credits are just,
they don't say who the actual people are.
They just sort of say their roles.
Like, staring, ya know, "a douche-bag who's paid too much" or "the comic relief" or "a CGI character".
Like, they're saying all this stuff you see in a milliion movies,
and you're gonna see in this movie too.
So it's, I don't know...
Maybe that's kinda like the secret genius of it,
Is that it actually is just an unbelievably standard movie.
That just has such a good sense of humor that it's kind of like eh, you kinda take it.
But the humor doesn't go through all the way through,
and I don't think that's what Deadpool was, from what I understand.
I don't think it was one-hundred-percent comedy.
It is still a comic book film, it is still about revenge.
It is still about kicking ass and a lot of cool stunts and powers.
And people looking really pained and angsty and going "Nooo!"
Ya know, all of that stuff. So that's all in there.
And yeah, I guess...
Maybe I thought it was going to be a little bit more unique in that sense.
I mean, I hear Deadpool, one of his big comedic things
is that he constantly compares himself to other characters.
Like Spiderman, or Wolverine 'cause he can heal up,
and then Spiderman because he kinda looks like Spiderman.
So...
maybe that's kinda the thing.
Maybe they kinda know they're stealing from all these other things
and they're kinda having fun with it.
Um... But if it- If it was, it was taking itself pretty seriously,
But, I don't know, I guess something like Darkman does something kinda similar.
It doesn't have fourth-wall jokes, but it's this very obvious standard plot
that you've seen in comic books a million times.
But it gives it its own unique spin.
So, yeah, I think when it sort of came around to being this
dramatic film, the part where you're supposed to really care.
With the exception of the romance, which surprisingly I really bought the chemistry,
uh, I thought everything else was just kinda standard, like I've seen it a lot.
There was even one or two times where I was kinda like:
"Yeah, okay, where's the.. can he look at the camera again."
But um, but it's good.
I guess I thought maybe I'd get something a little bigger.
Or even more jokes flying out at you.
But I'll be honest, I'm probably
really spoiled with what I thought this was gonna be.
Cause like I said, I mean I am kinda thinking like the Cornetto Trilogy, or Hot Fuzz or something like that,
where there's just gonna be a ton of jokes.
Um, and there are a fair amount of jokes, and very clever jokes.
There's, the opening credits like I said are very funny.
There's a great scene where he spells out the bad guy's name, I won't give it away.
Uh, some really funny one-liners.
Um, so, yeah it's fun.
It's a fun, shoot-em-up action flick with some funny lines.
A butt-ton of in-jokes as you'd imagine. And... Most of 'em I got.
There's one or two-
Like he meets a guy who's like, his best friend,
I think called Bob or something like that.
And the audience just *woah* like that,
and I went, "huh?"
And these guys in front of me were trying to tell me
like, "No, it's his best friend from a while ago,
he's the one that always gets him in trouble, he's the one..."
I'm like "okay, okay, alright, that's...
You got it, you're the people that this was made for and that's what matters".
And that's what I feel like, I feel like the crowd that saw this
really liked it, really got into it, and really laughed at every joke.
And I fe- and they applauded at the end.
They waited, like nobody left before the credits stopped.
Everybody stayed 'cause they knew there was gonna be something at the end.
So I think that's, that's the kinda people this was made for.
It was made for fans, it kinda feels like a fan movie.
I took my wife to go see it, who, y'know, she liked it fine.
But there was a lot of times where she was like:
"What's that? I don't know that. What does that mean? What is that?"
Y'know, there's references to "Wolverine Origins", and the Stan Lee cameo.
So there's all this stuff that, unless you know Marvel and comic book movies
and stuff like that, you're not gonna get.
This is very much, it feels like a fan film,
but kind of the right kind of fan film.
So, yeah, it's fun.
Probably as anti-climactic of a review as you can get.
I don't love it but I thought it was, y'know, I thought it was fun.
It was an enjoyable film.
So, not much else I can say outside of that.
I'm not going to do a spoiler corner 'cause there's really nothing to spoil.
I mean, what you guess is gonna happen is exactly what happens.
But again, that's not the kinda movie it is.
It's there for the jokes, it's there to get this incredibly popular character on the big screen.
And it seems like it's done well.
All the cosplayers I see at cons and the way they act, they all act like this asshole.
So, I'm assuming this is what the character is like.
So, yeah, if uh, if you're lookin' for some good laughs,
and some fun action and just CG superheroes jumpin' around punching stuff.
This is great, it's a lot of fun, and it's gory.
And there's, y'know, it's raunchy, it definitely earns its R rating.
So, um, yeah...
That's about it, uh, take it for what it's worth,
and I will see you later. Take care.